so of course the first reaction is
relief
because because our whole team
the whole company all collaborators uh
were awaiting this
this results anxiously and as you know
this is a clinical trial and a clinical
trial can be positive and it could be
negative
and only when we heard that the trial is
positive and very
very positive we were relieved and and
after the relief
happiness are you now feeling the weight
of what
is literally global expectation
yeah of course of course the situation
is
we feel a huge responsibility
but on the other side i'm also happy
that we are not alone
there are a number of companies uh who
will publish their results in
the coming weeks yeah and i expect
expect that many of this result will be
positive because the immune responses
that have been public
uh for some of the candidates are also
good yeah so i
feel that that that we are not alone
yeah so we will
contribute for uh to control this
pandemic but we will do it together with
other companies
when do you expect or hope
that this vaccine will make it to the
public
so we are we are at the moment in in
in a close uh dialogue with
regulators around the world we are
talking to the european medicinal agency
we are talking to the fda
we are talking to canada in health to
the
to the uk authorities to the chinese
authorities to japanese authorities
and the first first authorizations or
conditional approvals could happen in
the united states or in
in europe and but the earliest time
point for starting supplying vaccine
will most likely not be for mid of
december
and this middle of december will also
not mean that the situation will
dramatically change
so we have to expect that that this will
be really uh
a difficult winter it will become worse
before it
it it gets better so we will feel the
first reliefs in the
in the starting with march april uh
next year and ideally we would have a
controlled better control situation in
mid
of next next year but but you actually
anticipate it is possible
people will be getting doses of your
vaccine
in december this year in the uk and
elsewhere
it could be possible depending on on the
decision-making process of the of the
authorities
are there any european countries that
you think have dealt with it better than
others i mean i don't know what is your
perception if or how much you know
about the uk approach to covid
yeah it is i think i think the situation
how the companies dealt with
is is really really at the beginning it
was different
in in because because the the different
european countries
had different strategies and it was not
clear which strategy is the right one
yeah and now uh
now everyone knows how to deal with that
yeah and the most important aspect
is really carry a mask yeah if you if
you leave the home
if you are with other people and carry
ideally
uh certified mass so that that that this
this further reduces the risk be careful
yeah
so i think we have the responsibility
everyone has the responsibility it's not
only
about governments it's really about
everyone understanding
that the next month will will be still
difficult
yeah so we will have a difficult time
uh in the winter and the situation
will most likely relax beginning spring
yeah
and with all the vaccines available next
year
we could return maybe to a normal life
mid of next year and until then we need
to be patient and
and disciplined and i suppose you're
reminding people
that a vaccine is not a panacea that
there's lots of other things that you
have to do to control kovid
yeah absolutely absolutely so it's it's
it's really we can protect ourselves so
peop
so everyone needs to understand and that
that
that that caring mask and and either
and avoiding the too many people
are too long in one room is the best way
to prevent the spread of this this virus
and and if we stick to that i think we
will we will we will
manage uh to further reduce the
infections
infections and and then with uh with
with the spring and the warmer days
coming back
yeah we will have a have a higher
likelihood here to control the pandemic
yeah
and with vaccines coming with sufficient
doses
we may we may avoid a next hot winter in
2021